[Music]
[Applause]
Tom pellicero on loan from NFL Network
and co-hosting good morning football
joining us here a couple of things I
wanted to talk to you about I know it's
kind of quiet in June for the NFL but I
was wondering when Sean McDermott got
his contract extension first thing I
thought was
this a guy who could get fired if they
don't go to the AFC title game it feels
like this year and am I making more out
of this with Sean McDermott than uh I
should be
I think that those extensions which
really were done from my understanding
quite a while ago it wasn't something
that just happened after the Stefan
Diggs thing this were you know a lot of
times they want to get the GI I'm the
head coach done at the same time so if
one contract's done early they don't
announce anything until you get later on
to the off season with Sean McDermott in
the bills I think that
there's there's a lot of the the
national narrative seems to be missing
the circumstances of last season I mean
they've built a stable program in a
place that did not have a winning
culture for a long time previous to that
you go back to the end of October last
season the bills are six and one they
had beaten the Chiefs at Arrowhead
Stadium from that point forward the
following week first week of November
Josh Allen messes up his elbow and he
was not right for months he was wearing
a brace for a while that altered his
mechanics he finally shed it toward the
end of the year and was throwing the
ball again but he really had to work
through it it was a significant injury
Von Miller tears his ACL you had the
game that was moved at the last minute
to Detroit that was one of their home
games they played three games away from
home in a 12-day span you had the Demar
Hamlin situation that right before you
know the beginning of the playoffs
because that was I believe a week 17
game and that up ended everything and
created all these different questions
and of course also I mean the bills are
the first team in modern NFL history
that had watch one of their teammates
literally die on the field and come back
to life and there are other
circumstances throughout the course of
the Season you go back to training camp
Dalton knox's uh brother tragically
passed away uh Kim pagula the owner had
a heart condition he has not returned to
the team and she was really omnipresent
with that building listen everybody's
got an adversity everybody's got
injuries but the number of things that
happened to the bills particularly in
the second half of the season I don't
think should be discounted because you
know mentally physically emotionally it
really did take a toll on that team
you're hoping now if you're
hang on Josh Allen's gonna have a
healthy elbow and they're going to be
not have any type of tragedies happen to
them through the course of the Season
maybe this team's going to be pretty
good I I don't knock at the sense that
all the Sean McDermott is on the hot
seat okay in Buffalo obviously there's a
lot of different things that can happen
but I think you have to take the context
of last season with um you know when
you're talking about evaluate in the
future in Buffalo uh Brandon Staley Mike
McCarthy those seats warm
depends how they play I mean with in
Dallas I think that there's always I
mean listen if the Cowboys losing week
one there's gonna be people talking
about should they blow it up and should
they make major changes that's the
nature of being with the Cowboys you
know what I think is interesting with
them is Jerry Jones zadie years old we
know how desperately Jerry wants to win
a Super Bowl yeah you look at the things
that they've done since Mike McCarthy's
gotten there they haven't made desperate
type of moves they haven't gone all in
on a single season they're building
through the draft which McCarthy
believes in and then supplementing with
low risk types of moves you know the
Brandon Cooks trade costs them virtually
nothing the Stefan Gilmore trade was for
a fifth round conditional pick you add
some of those guys but that program is
built through you know it's going to be
Micah Parsons and it's going to be
Trayvon Diggs it's going to be CD lamb
and obviously Dak Prescott they want to
get a deal done with Tony Pollard you
know those are Who You're Building
through here so I think that you know
externally well I understand that
there's always that heightened level of
of angst or speculation or whatever you
want to call it in Dallas everything
I've heard I mean Jerry is a believer in
what Mike McCarthy is building there now
McCarthy obviously takes a lot on his
shoulders here because he's now called
the plays Kellen Moore has moved on to
the charger so that's one more way that
things are going to be directed to Mike
if this doesn't go right but you know
Mike's had a lot of successes to play
caller within the league
um they're going to do some things
differently schematically and
philosophically even though they're
still working in the language the deck
is used to here
um yeah so obviously if things don't go
well I think the public look at the
Cowboys could be different than what's
happening internally it just depends how
the season goes and then with regard to
the Chargers you know Brandon Staley's
in the third year of his contract they
have been you know a productive football
team particularly on offense over his
first couple of years and he made the
Bold move of picking up killing Moore
who became available because it became
apparent in Dallas that they were going
to make some changes there they really
think that that's going to unlock some
things with Justin Herbert I think
inevitably when you've got a really good
Young quarterback and you've got the
amount of talent that the Chargers have
on the team results are gonna are gonna
drive a lot of different things here but
the Chargers have also not made a habit
of firing coaches with money left on
their contracts uh and there's a belief
level in Brandon Staley I mean they
remade some things in this off season
they entrusted him to make the change
with the offensive coordinator they're
Believers in what they potentially can
be from a Personnel perspective as well
because and I hate to make it sound like
we're making excuses for all these teams
because again everybody's got injuries
but they won a bunch of games last year
where Justin Herbert was doing it almost
entirely on his own he didn't have his
left tackle Ray Sean Slater for almost
the entire season it seemed like they
never had the three of their wide
receivers together at the same time
defensively Joey bosom this time here
when James missing time JC Jackson was
their big scorer in free agency he
didn't really play the entire season
they're set up I I think that they're
the team that nobody's really talking
about here and I got a chance to talk to
Brandon Staley about a week ago here you
know he's he's very confident in what
they've built they thought that they had
a really good draft they built a
basketball team in that wide receiver
room I think they're gonna be a really
fun team to watch because Kelly Morris
had some really productive offenses and
I think that uh we all as football fans
like to see Justin Herbert throwing it
all over the place boy leave it to Tom
pellicero to let the air out of this
segment where I thought we might have
coaches on the hot seat is there is
there any coach who's on the hot seat
going into this season
I mean I think that you know inevitably
the coaches I always look at it this way
if a Coach is going into year three and
they've not won a playoff game then you
can fairly say that there's going to be
speculation about their job right
because not many guys get an opportunity
if they don't want to play off game for
three years you come back for year four
so Brandon Staley would fall into that
category Mike McCarthy fell into that
category the year before I think Sean
McDermott's in a different spot just
because they have one as consistently as
they have yeah you want to get to the
mountain cop here but you know there's
always a degree of Randomness and even
luck that come from winning the Super
Bowl you know you have to get into the
playoffs every year you got to build the
strongest roster possible but sometimes
you know your starting quarterback has
an elbow injury it takes them down the
stretch sometimes you know various
circumstances can put you not at 100
going into the playoffs uh the fact that
Buffalo has been there over and over I
think puts him in a good spot just like
in Dallas again I understand where
people you know take aim at Mike
McCarthy here but you know what have
they done the covert year in 2020 it's
really hard to to Really establish a
culture there that was a struggle they
didn't have the right defensive
coordinator they brought in Dan Quinn
and things turned around 2021 they get
in the playoffs 2022 they win a playoff
game if they don't pick that next step
and get to the original playoffs or get
to the conference Championship game then
I think it's natural for anybody
including Jerry Jones to say okay are we
doing the right things here but there's
a belief level with Jerry and Mike
that's at a higher level than I think a
lot of people externally realize in
Dallas I know that the NFL and HBO don't
want to hold a team hostage but it feels
like they're pretty close to holding the
Jets hostage for Hard Knocks here uh I
mean objectively is there anyone who
doesn't work for the Jets who doesn't
want to see the Jets on Hard Knocks like
in the end if there's not a team just
raising their hand and going we
absolutely want to do it if you gotta
you know nudge somebody into the Jets
are the natural team I mean Aaron
Rodgers is obviously a fascinating story
but you know so is Robert solid they got
a lot of bright young players on that
team they got some big Personalities in
that building guys like Nathaniel
Hackett who you know is certainly going
to be motivated to show you know how
smart of a coach he is which is
something that Aaron Rodgers has said
repeatedly even when Hackett was going
through his struggles uh last year in
Denver you know the commanders you can
make a case for them too because they're
going to have you know you want to have
a coaches on the hot seat I think Ron
Rivera naturally with a new ownership
group coming in he's been there for four
years yeah he's going to be somebody who
you look if they don't make the playoffs
here yeah his job is uh potentially
going to be uh in doubt but they've got
so they got that they've got a potential
quarterback competition because Sam
Howell still has to hold off to Kobe
Brissette he got the chase young
situation that's playing out there as
well the team is being sold
um all those things think make them a
compelling case too but it's hard to
beat the Jets for drama so unless
there's a a firm if you want if you want
us to do this you're going to catch a
lot of hell because of it from us uh for
however many years to come I I just
think that the judge are The Logical fit
but we'll see how it all Nets out but
you know what would be great if they did
hard knocks on the Jets and the Jets
openly didn't want to accommodate them
that's part of the HBO Hard Knocks is
the Jets don't want to be on Hard Knocks
but they're still trying to film all
this stuff so you'll almost get that you
know tension animosity towards the
camera Crews and every you know maybe
maybe make it interesting right the
teams also get the final cut on these
things I mean they get to see the show
before it airs they can say we need to
take things out if you get a team that's
not volunteering for it that doesn't
necessarily want to be on the show then
maybe you're not getting as good a stuff
as for instance we got last year with
Detroit which really did run at the ball
because they wanted to show all the Dank
or should be Dan Campbell is a lot
there's a lot more to that guy than one
sound bite from a press conference two
and a half years ago and I think that he
showed that both on the show and uh
based on what they did in the second
half last season on the field it's Trey
Lance further away
to being an NFL quarterback or closer to
being an NFL quarterback
Trey Lance because even when he was
coming out of college at North Dakota
State the people who had doubts about
Trey Lance would just say he started I
want to say it was 15 games total in
college and he averaged like 22 passes
or something like that over those games
he played one game during the covet
season it was not a very good game and
all the issues about you know ball
placement accuracy those kind of popped
up a little bit in that game and we just
haven't seen him you know the biggest
thing was he needed to play football he
needed to get reps because everybody
loves Trey Lance as a guy from
everything that I've heard he attacks it
there he studies he's picked up the
offense quickly but the two knocks on
him have been it's the injuries and it's
accuracy well he has been injured and
because of those injuries he's not been
able to get the Reps to work on the
accuracy so I I don't know what Trey
Lance is and I don't think the 49ers
ultimately know what he can be either
and neither is anybody else within the
league that's where you know there's
certainly still a possibility the tray
Lance could be traded they're going to
want to get you know down line here and
see what Brock Purdy has going on
they're going to want to see Sam darnold
they're probably going to want to see
does anybody get hurt during training
camp because if there's any team that
should have a healthy level of paranoia
about injuries at the quarterback
position it's San Francisco
um but what are you getting for Trey
Lance right now you traded multiple
first round picks to go up and get him a
couple of years ago there's no tape to
show hey this is a guy who we think
should be a starting quarterback
someplace so it's a difficult type of
calculus there I would anticipate the
Brock party is the starting quarterback
for the 49ers everything that I have
heard on Brock Purdy his rehab since
that uh internal brace surgery has been
positive to this point he went down to
Jacksonville yesterday he's working out
with Will Hewlett and Tom Gormley on
some mechanical things you wouldn't be
doing that for a couple of weeks in June
and July if you were worried about you
know taxing your arm and things like
that this little process he's got to go
through here but every expectation right
now for the 49ers and for Brock party
that he's out there ready to go for the
season finish this sentence if the
Arizona Cardinals end up with the worst
record in football
it's probably the best thing that can
happen to them based on where they at
are at from a team building perspective
listen we all know what's going on in
the draft next year you got Caleb
Williams you got Drake may you have
other quarterbacks who potentially can
play their way into that conversation uh
as we get through the 2023 season here
and the Cardinals are at a point where
you've got a new regime there uh
Jonathan Gannon and Monty Austin for it
a quarterback they didn't draft in Kyler
Murray and a quarterback who's not going
to be out there uh at the start of the
season and all I think he's coming off
of the torn ACL they will be in position
to draft the quarterback that would mean
moving on obviously from Kyler Murray
his contract is very tradable it would
have been tradable even if they had
wanted to trade him prior to this season
but with an injury no he's gonna trade
for a quarterback who's coming off of
that level of an injury and is probably
going to miss the majority of this
season now I'll also say the new regime
has wrapped their arms around Kyler
Murray we saw the photos of them you
know took the plane and went to his uh
statue unveiling at Oklahoma everything
that I've heard is that he's been in the
meetings and he's been active and the
new coaching staff you know likes him
but again you're going to own
potentially a really high pick in the
2024 draft and you've got that once in a
lifetime type of opportunity uh to go
take the quarterback that you want also
don't forget I thought it was really
interesting a manias and four proceeded
through the 2023 draft his first in
charge it was very much motivated by
getting additional picks next year so
they got a one in 2024 I believe they
have two extra twos in 2024. so even if
they win some games which listen
Jonathan Gannon his personality the the
t word is not going to come out of his
mouth he's still going to go into this
like we're going to try to make the best
of this thing and go try and win some
games uh but even if you somehow win
five six games there and you drop and
you don't have the number one pick
they've got as much ammunition as
anybody to go up and get one of those
quarterbacks if they want to I think one
of the really interesting story lines
this season then will be when Kyler
Murray is cleared or that's October
November December depending you know on
the severity of his injury what exactly
he's ready
how soon do they put him out there how
much of Kyler Murray do they want to see
on the field especially knowing that
maybe that's the guy who wins you the
game
in draft position as well and then you
also run the risk of him getting hurt
um it's a really interesting thing there
I know that that staff is really focused
on you know establishing their culture
and things like that but you're right to
bring that up I mean there's a decent
chance that they're gonna have a really
high pick here uh and they're gonna have
to make an evaluation at the quarterback
position thanks for taking time Tom we
appreciate it
NFL Network Insider and co-hosting good
morning football this week